only on CBS this morning we are hearing
from two women who accused Virginia's
lieutenant governor of sexual assault
Vanessa Tyson and Meredith Watson want
the state legislature which reconvenes
in two days to hold a public hearing
where they can testify under oath
against Justin Fairfax they came forward
back in February after some lawmakers
called on Virginia governor Ralph
Northam
to resign over races yearbook photo now
if Northam had resigned fairfax would
have likely replaced him fairfax denies
the woman's allegations Tysons of
politics professor was the first to go
public she claims that Justin Fairfax
assaulted her during the 2004 Democratic
National Convention in Boston some of
the details she shares with us are very
disturbing what were your impressions of
him well he seemed very friendly very
charismatic harmless even we he's told
me that he was at Columbia Law School
and I and we realized we had a mutual
friend so we immediately struck up a
conversation so you felt you had
established a semi rapport with him yes
certainly I mean it wasn't flirtatious
at all did you feel safe with him I
certainly felt he was harmless there
were no red flags that suggested to me
that he was a threat so how do you end
up in his hotel room on the Wednesday of
the convention so roughly 48 hours after
I've met him he suggests that he has to
run an errand did I want to come with
him and get a bit of fresh air and
sunshine it's you know early afternoon
what does he tell you that he's going to
the hotel to do what is he just needed
to pick up some paperwork okay is what
he said which sounded completely
legitimate to me you're there in the
hotel standing by the door and then what
happened he crosses the room and you
know kind of goes through his luggage
find some paperwork right which is what
I assumed we were there for he's good
and then he crosses back around the bed
and comes over to me and I'm still by
the door and he kisses me and you think
well I was surprised
you know like for a variety of reasons I
was surprised but it wasn't unwelcome
per se you're saying it wasn't unwelcome
and you're kissing him and you're okay
with the kissing yeah okay kissing yeah
you know and he kind of gently takes my
hands and guides me towards the bed and
we're still kissing right and it's
completely consensual he guides me to
the bed and then you know he sits down
on the bed and what happens from there
you know we start kissing lying down but
on the very edge of the bed okay so I'm
following and then what happens we're
kissing lying down and we're kissing
like so our heads are level with each
other and then it was like my neck
didn't work what do you mean it was like
I couldn't I couldn't feel my neck I
couldn't hold my head up
he's using his hand on the back of my
neck and I still didn't know what was
going wrong I thought there was
something wrong with my neck and he's
pushing down and pushing down and I
couldn't hold my neck up and I didn't
know what was going on I honestly didn't
know what was going on and then the next
thing I know like my head is like
literally in his crotch and I'm choking
and gagging and you know I couldn't say
anything because I'm choking and gagging
and so you know it continues for and
it's holding my head so I can't lift
like I'm trying to lift my head but I
can't is he saying anything to you
Vanessa nothing there's nothing and what
are you thinking at this moment to be
honest I'm a total shock I think do you
say anything to him no
I didn't know what to say I I was just I
was completely caught off guard it was
almost as if I was dumbstruck have you
talked to Justin Fairfax since that day
in 2004 the next day I remember blocking
it was the last day of the convention
and I remember walking you know I was
walking towards the staff lounge I was
gonna go in there and I saw I'm in there
and you know he didn't see me
and I just you know did a 180 and just
went the absolute opposite direction
like I just didn't want you know didn't
even want him to see me didn't want him
no so you you really haven't seen him
since that incident in 2004 no I haven't
seen him I remember him trying to call
me a couple of times but I I just didn't
pick up this was after the convention
was over and I think he emailed me a few
times as well like I never initiated
contact did you tell anyone that this
has happened why didn't you tell anyone
Vanessa I was so ashamed
I was so humiliated uh none so many
levels like here I was this woman
working at a rape crisis center you know
trying to like as a survivor speaker
trying to empower survivors of sexual
assault and it was like I just walked
into a trap you just mentioned that you
were a survivor speaker that you work at
a rape crisis center yes you were a
survivor of what of incest it was just
an aware of this in your past actually
yes actually shared that with him yes
you felt comfortable enough sharing that
with him even though you had just met
him here's the thing
what I was doing for the rape crisis
center was actually
probably the biggest part of my life at
that time do you feel he took advantage
of you knowing your past
in retrospect yes no lieutenant governor
Fairfax responded to the accusations in
a statement to CBS News he says this I
feel so strongly regarding my innocence
that I submitted myself to polygraph
tests for each of the accusations
against me I passed these tests because
as I've maintained from the very
beginning I did not assault either of my
accusers now there's one question in the
polygraph where he was asked whether
Vanessa contacted him after the Boston
Convention in order to meet her mother
he says that he answered yes truthfully
to that question Vanessa says she never
contacted him after the incident it was
fascinating talking to her because I
felt at some point it's almost like she
was going back to the moment that you
could see that you could really see that
in her eyes and people could say yeah
but she went to the hotel room yes she
agreed to the kissing isn't that on her
but I could see as a young person you
have a you have a mutual friend and you
think this guy is safe and kissing
doesn't necessarily have to lead to what
she says happened after that something
totally changed when she was walking
through what transpired and you can see
where she got very emotional into that
dark place
yeah it was like she was forced yeah